China is hiring the West's own
ex-military Pilots to train their
military Pilots to fight the West what
are you talking about let me explain so
you're China and you want to invade
Taiwan you are sure that invading Taiwan
would probably be a cakewalk your
military is way more powerful than
theirs so that is not really a concern
what is concerning is the fact that if
you invaded America and NATO would
definitely come to taiwan's rescue
willing to get involved militarily to
defend Taiwan if it comes to that yes
you are that's the commitment we made
America needs taiwan's computer chips in
order to survive they've got skin in the
game which means it's pretty much
guaranteed they'll be defending Taiwan
if you invade Biden even said so himself
U.S forces U.S men and women would
defend Taiwan in the event of a Chinese
Invasion yes this would not be good
because America's military is the most
powerful in the world and if the US goes
to war all their NATO allies would be
obligated to join the fight against you
so on top of the US you would have to go
up against all of me needle as well you
would not stand a chance unless you
start to play a little dirty see if the
West were to defend Taiwan a big part of
their operation would be their Air Force
the West has the fastest most powerful
most dangerous fighter jets in the world
so if you want to stand a chance in the
scenario you'll need to know exactly how
Western fighter pilots think how they
plan out their missions with their
Center operating procedures are how they
organize their forces for an attack what
are their weaknesses because if you can
learn exactly how the enemy is gonna
fight you can crush them luckily we have
a very simple solution to this problem
simply call up a bunch of retired
Western pilots and bribe them with a
bunch of money surprisingly for
countries like the UK this is legal so
you go after dozens of retired military
pilots from the UK and Australia and
offer them huge salaries to train your
own military and since the UK government
never thought to put in laws against
this it's easy for your recruits to
accept your offer so now former British
and Australian Pilots are working
directly for the Chinese Army getting
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars
and revealing all the secrets the U.S
military has shared with their allies
over the years and it's all part of
their master plan let's just listen to
Chairman Z's words right now he's
telling his country to prepare for war
he's undergoing a massive military
buildup the Chinese Navy is now larger
than the U.S Navy their space force is
launching more than we are and they have
a massive nuclear modernization and he's
telling his military to be ready to stop
the United States from intervening by
2027. stay dangerous and let's get into
it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're watching this channel you
probably like to know what's really
going on in the world the problem is
news outlets are extremely biased some
are way too biased to the left some are
way too biased to the rights and most of
them are owned by rich people or giant
media conglomerates so you end up having
to read a bunch of different media
Outlets to get to the truth it takes way
too much time and that's why I was super
excited when I found out about ground
news ground news is a media platform
that makes it easy to compare different
news sources allowing you to avoid media
bias ground news goes through 60 000
news articles every single day from over
50 000 different sources then they take
all these different pieces and merge
them into a single story that gives you
a variety of perspectives on the same
story and what's cool about ground news
is that you can swipe through headlines
to see how different Outlets cover the
same story you can even see a visual
breakdown of where sources lean
politically for a story and you can even
see an international perspective to
learn how the same stories are covered
all around the world using their map
feature ground news is a breath of fresh
air it's saved me a ton of time it's
prevented me from getting sucked into
Echo Chambers and I highly recommend you
try out too take advantage of the ground
news Black Friday sale and get 40 off
Advantage subscription sale ends
December 2nd
so check out ground news for free by
going to ground.new slash jaketran
that's ground.news Jake tram with the
link below thanks to ground news for
sponsoring this video
China hiring foreign Pilots to jack up
their military is nothing new during
World War II the Chinese government
recruited a bunch of retired American
fighter pilots to train their own Air
Force
and at the time this was totally fine
America was on China's side believe it
or not and China's military was pretty
weak at the time these Pilots are still
celebrated to this day for helping
liberate China from the Japanese they
were called The Flying Tigers and were
literally considered Heroes of the sky
but today is different today the US and
China are in a cold war together and the
U.S has got to do everything in their
power to make sure Taiwan doesn't fall
into the hands of China
America does not run on Dunkin Donuts
believe it or not it runs on computer
chips computer chips are arguably as
important of a resource as oil is and we
know what America has been willing to do
for oil in the past
so what would America be willing to do
if Taiwan and therefore 65 percent of
the world's computer chips were at stake
so you gotta prepare China's military as
much as possible so you start by sending
out Headhunters to recruit retired
pilots from the UK and Australia
now one may think that come on those are
veterans for crying out loud they're
patriotic loyal to their country they
would never betray that loyalty to work
for you and that may be true for most
veterans but not all of them these
Pilots are in their mid-50s and some of
them have debts to pay kids to feed kids
in college child support and since
they've been deemed too old to continue
to fly military craft and blow stuff up
their only option now is to teach
unfortunately the average salary for a
UK military pilot instructor is only a
measly eighty thousand dollars so when
you offer these guys 270
000 a year to train your Cadets in
Western Warfare it's almost guaranteed
that at least some of them are gonna be
interested and just to sweeten the deal
even more you also opted to cover their
travel expenses along with all expenses
paid luxury apartments even better they
won't even have to live in China for the
job have them work at a flight school in
South Africa where you'll send your
Pilots to get trained that way you can
stay discreet and what do you know all
of a sudden you've got 30 British Pilots
signed up to your new training program
pulled by UK Media Company bfbs showed
that three-quarters of British Armed
Forces said they would not train China's
Army for any amount of money not even
270 thousand dollars however 17 said
that they would that's one in six
fighter pilots with a wealth of
knowledge that they could impart on you
pretty good odds and when the media
questioned these Pilots about their
betrayal they just argue that we're old
and out of touch any information we
share with China will be outdated and
irrelevant anyways that's the story they
stick to even though they know it's
definitely not entirely true
these retired Pilots are experts in the
operation of fighter jets like the
eurofighter typhoon sepikat Jaguar
carrier jump and panavia tornado these
are proven fighter jets that are still
being used in a ton of NATO countries
the UK's Royal Air Force the German air
force the French Air Force the Spanish
Navy the Italian Air Force and navy heck
one of them is still being used by the
United States Marine Corps as we speak
another one of them is even being used
by China's other arch nemesis India and
even though some of these models are no
longer being used by the US military
some new models are based on these
original designs and on top of that the
actual weapons are only a tiny part of
what wins a war tactics Logistics and
much more are also what wins Wars and
that's what these Western Pilots have
stored in their head and what's
surprising is that paying for this Intel
from the UK military is surprisingly not
at least not yet so you still have
plenty of time to attract all that
Priceless Knowledge from their heads and
into the heads of your own Airmen
when news broke about British Pilots
getting snatched up by the Chinese
military the UK government kinda
scrambled they realized that they
surprisingly don't have any laws against
retired Pilots training enemy forces and
this isn't normal for example the United
States has always had strict laws in
place as to what ex-military personnel
can and can't share after they retire
folks need to understand of course there
are export restrictions if I'm gonna
send a widget or a key military item or
a plane or a tank to a foreign country
much less an adversary like China but
there's also those kinds of controls on
our tactics you can't just go around the
world and teach anyone uh that you want
how we do our military planning or our
strategy or sniper skills or how uh to
dog fight or to counter our stealth
fighter capabilities but if you're a
British pilot apparently you can just go
ahead and take a job teaching the
Chinese Army your life's work and the UK
government can't do anything about it
unless it aligns with the official
Secrets Act
this act was established way back in
1911 and protects the British army from
Espionage by their own members and on
the surface it looks pretty promising
but there's just a tiny problem with the
wording according to the ACT members of
the royal armed forces can only be
prosecuted if actual evidence is found
of their betrayal and this evidence is
going to be pretty hard to find so as a
last-minute solution the UK proposed a
new law it's basically a two-strike rule
where Pilots suspected of collaborating
with China will be given a warning to
stop if they continue then they will
have broken the law and can be arrested
but as you know laws can take a long
time to get past and according to recent
reports 30 Pilots have already signed on
with the Chinese Army and who knows how
many other Pilots will sign on between
now and the passing of this new law I
can't believe that the British uh don't
have those types of restrictions as well
it's evident that China is planning
something big on only time will tell if
and when they ever pull the trigger but
you can be sure we're going to keep you
updated on this channel so make sure you
subscribe
the United States and China are neck and
neck in terms of military power right
now China tops the list for largest army
with the highest number of soldiers
while the United States tops the list
for biggest military budget the U.S has
the money China has the Manpower all
China would need to do to push their
power over the edge is increase their
military budget which isn't all that
difficult considering just how crafty
China can be when it comes to making a
lot of money fast and one of the best
examples of this comes from the 1970s
when the Chinese government withdrew all
their Public Funding to hospitals in the
military in one swift motion which meant
both of these groups suddenly had to
come up with their own source of income
so they looked around and figured hey we
have all these knives scalpels and
operating tools we also have millions of
healthy citizens with nice juicy organs
why not sell organs to Rich westerners
genius
and so boom China's profitable forced
organ harvesting industry was born where
prisoners get their organs removed by
force to sell to wealthy westerners and
we would love to show you exactly how
these Chinese hospitals managed to pull
off the largest forced organ harvesting
operation in history but if we posted
this publicly our channel would get
instantly demonetized which is why we
decided to really solve this info as a
full-length private documentary only
available to members of this Channel all
you have to do to get instant access to
the profitable business of forced organ
harvesting and tons of other secret docs
on topics like Jeffrey Epstein MK Ultra
and CIA black sites is to click the join
button below and unlike University we're
not going to charge you thousands of
dollars only to leave you in the dark
about how the world really works it only
going to be five dollars a month and
there's a refund policy too unlike most
YouTube memberships so if you join and
you don't think it's worth it email us
within your first month of joining for
the first time and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there is no refund